- But Happy Thanksgiving, by the way.
- Thank you very much.
- Yeah, that's so sweet.
- I'm gonna put my gut hider on.
- I love it.
(all laughing)
- Thank you very much.
Whew, now I can relax.
- Now it's out.
I love you right now.
Well wait, this is...
All of this is...
It's like we're related, but, so wait.
Today is all about gratitude,
which I think is perfect for you.
We were trying to find, 'cause
we love you on this show.
We've had you on and we're like-
- That's very sweet.
- "What can we do
that's like different and special?"
And Thanksgiving was this week.
And you're such a giving person,
but I think that you're
also always in a state of,
like, gratitude for everything
as well, which is cool.
'Cause you recognize all the blessings.
- Yeah, Amen.
Well, you're that same way.
- [Kelly] I am but you're
like the next degree.
We've talked about this-
- Oh, really?
- Me and my friends, yeah.
Everybody thought I was
like this and then they...
You were introduced in
their life (laughing).
And they're like, "Oh no,
you don't even count."
But what does it mean to like be grateful,
especially around Thanksgiving?
Like, what do you, go big for
Thanksgiving, your family?
- Yeah well, when you're married to-
- Well.
- One of the greatest
cooks on the planet.
- Oh, my God.
Don't brag about it.
- Well, I won't.
We'll talk about how great of a singer
she is next.
- Oh, yeah.
- And then we'll talk
about that that's probably
five and six on our list
of top 10 things to do.
- [Kelly] Yeah, aww.
- But she, I think it's fun.
My thing is this, and you
guys might feel the same way.
When it comes to the future, you know,
I think it's what you're just grateful for
is just one more day, right?
- Yeah.
- Of getting to do this.
So I think that's it.
Just truthfully, if I could
say, what I'd love to say is
the day I take my last
breath on this planet,
I'd love for my three
girls to be around me.
And I'd love for the
queen to be around me.
But as far as Miss Yearwood, I don't know.
You know, I've said this before.
I found her in the past life.
I'll find her in the next.
- Aww.
(audience exclaiming)
Well, have a great day, everybody.
(Garth chuckling)
(audience applauding)
- She makes it fun, you know?
- Yeah, no,
- She makes it really fun.
- I'm gonna cry at lunch, Garth.
Okay, so it is amazing though.
It's such a beautiful love
between the two of you.
It is.
And you are tearing up, and
you're making me tear up,
and my makeup artist is gonna kill me.
- [Garth] I'm not tearing up.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you are.
Yeah, you are, I love it.